hey before you watch the show and enjoy
it hopefully but I have no control over
how you feel please do consider joining
up at laterals credit comm slash mug
Club you have four or five more shows
every single week as well as the entire
blaze TV catalog you get this wonderful
hand etched mug and more importantly
it's what allows us to continue this
show and put any of this content on
YouTube because this isn't where
everyone here makes their bones so
louder was crater comm slash mug Club
and of course if you're on YouTube
you're not there yet from mug club hit
the notification bell and hit all
notifications
enjoy the show experts are now saying
that binge watching online content makes
climate change worse hardest hit by the
news actually is Greta foon Berg who
just signed a new 15 million-dollar
Netflix deal for her stand-up debut so
she's not going on yeah how dare you how
dare you my sister-in-law
somewhat frequently probably every 10 to
20 minutes or so reaches down and
scratches her lady business she just
like out scratch fighter monkey picking
10 I think that they pile on this guy
like he's done nothing right he walked
into politics and he slapped the entire
system and he spoke to politicians in a
way they've never been spoken to and all
of these elitists that thought if you
voted for Trump you're a racist
well dumbbells that's why he won the
Commission
I won't call them dumbbells it's right
next to cornball certainly a dumbbells
is always good coming out
[Music]
louder with Crowder studios protected
exclusively by Walter
thousands of people demonstrated
nationwide Saturday for the 4th annual
women's March thousands of women and the
allies have flooded the streets across
the UN thirds of people in downtown
Dallas today for the fourth annual
women's March going on now in our
national government we're going back to
the 50 the Dallas women's March and
March is all over the country not about
Trump for years in the women's March
target hasn't changed
one two three
hello ladies no debate is a trap
maybe to respect women so you should
respect women and the woman so [ __ ] you
I feared and say
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
ah that's the shoulder this is called
the only dance I can do because I've
injured my lower back I wonder if that's
you invented to dust your shoulders off
it's just a lazy quadriplegic well I
guess we carefully otherwise it would
just be right on the show we'll be
talking about a OCS recent I guess we'd
say interview for MLK Day and everything
you need to know about impeachment I'm
sorry we do have to get to it but first
question of the day a OSI as we'll get
to she recently said that the Democratic
Party is not left enough that there is
no actual left party that they're merely
centrists do you think that the DNC
today is moderate and specifically the
self-professed centrists out there I
want to hear from you if you're a
centrist or moderate where do you feel
the most comfortable
in today's political spectrum also why
are you such a fence sitting [ __ ]
that's what I would like to know do you
believe that someone can truly be an
Ozzy Osbourne fan and not at all
familiar with Ronnie James Dio s catalog
I think he's a liar let me know oh wow
my half-asian lawyer bill Richman is
here thank you sir frigging he's talking
like it's NPR you so doc I don't like
that at all audio way to keep Manny G
Morgan Jr Gerald a what's the wine of
the one of the day is red schooner
Stephen and actually it's a wine of the
world red schooner comes from Argentina
made in Califano there's 20 more minutes
of stories just goes and does conjugal
visits to put a smile on their faces a
lot to get to but first well well this
this clip had to be first the patriarchy
Donald Trump my pen
white supremacy racism misogyny
homophobia I didn't even look like she's
passionate about it she just looks like
she's going off a list gets her grocery
list of I'm here in front of the White
House I am NOT here for polite pentest
patriarchy is not polite I am not yet
Ronald McDonald why is she flipping her
friend of Cairo Egypt where I'm from the
new geography across the world the
patriarchy every time
and the patriarchy keep every
two hours late I hate this is my life
the New York Times has endorsed both
Elizabeth Warren and Amy Klobuchar
Democratic primaries this is a quote
from the contest is between moderates
and progressives and the paper felt the
two were the most effective advocates
for each approach and some by the way
even feel that a joint ticket with the
two women could bring sort of these two
rivaling factions in the DNC together
and is that quote of like it I'm getting
word that actually the two are holding a
surprise joint press conference on just
that now good with the live censoring
president which by the way would explain
the initially confusing recent
endorsement from Julian Castro yeah holy
and Castro goose news what he goosed us
make sense now McMahon's gonna go sign
up settable but they don't even taste
like apples what's the other
we like commercial
huh don't bring that Canadian noise oh
you know what it's good that he dropped
that when he did because he goosed us
them to ease too much to be trusted my
forefinger on the nuclear codes I don't
know I feel like we causative I'm not
easily distracted be like all right
Putin that's is that them now speaking
of the 2020 race of course people you
out there most likely know this if you
don't Tulsi Gabbard is now suing Hillary
Clinton for defamation good yeah yeah
good NBC news with suit states that
Clinton falsely stated Tulsi is a
Russian asset and a deliberate attempt
to derail her presidential campaign and
Hillary Clinton actually has responded
more recently I want to make sure I get
this right because you know lawsuits she
said this is just another absurd attack
in a long line of plate plate plate burp
lip flip Bert and she had another
seizure oh yeah she had a seizure which
you would think she wouldn't right blip
plenty yeah yeah yeah try to get the
message out you know what maybe she was
more committed than I thought maybe it
was code for 2020 Hillary please don't
Hillary and Klobuchar well anyway but
now we have a transition from that to
actually sad news sad news Diego a
famous hundred year old tortoise who was
instrumental by the way in preserving
species from extinction he was father to
over eight hundred tortoise baby Wow has
died unfortunately eight hundred Sousa
babies he was a busy tortoise and in
preparation for the public funeral where
people can pay their respects the
coroner has said that he's worked
incredibly long hours citing ten hours
to have Diego stuff to twelve hours
polishing his shell and twenty hours
required to wipe the smile off his face
so that there is tortoise national hero
actually he he didn't die just retired
oh he's just retired oh but that didn't
work for that Photoshop no so we lied
story about tortoises or tort I I don't
not so much about porpoises it's
basically a dolphin
yes it's a different time is it at all
for the man it's not it's often its
No so it's a sea mammal is it a whale or
more of a whale than a dolphin it's okay
all right
section who undoubtedly exists and knows
a lot about porpoises please let me know
we'll send you a free bag of black rifle
coffee because we accidentally double
ordered we're going up 30 pounds of
coffee very soon do porpoises they don't
they can't have coffees probably dogs
it's toss it toss clear we are porpoise
ignorant a public Jacqueline coming up
after this nation's executive with ties
to Jeffrey Epstein has now claimed that
the bad press she's gotten is just like
the Holocaust oh yeah yeah direct quote
let's do you think I'm making this up
like we did retired tortoise didn't die
but this one's real this is just on this
according to the PR powerhouse Peggy
Segal I'm getting on that train and I'm
going to the camps if I had been in Nazi
Germany it could not have been worse
oh of course historians dispute her
claims pointing to the most obvious
factual discrepancy in that Hitler
actually killed himself could not have
gone worse except for all the murder the
genocide in in German but by the way can
we be on the lookout for a follow-up
story I'm pretty sure after this gets
out it's gonna be worse yeah I think her
life is going to get a little worse now
yeah well I don't know she's probably
just a kind of person blissfully walks
through life comparing things to the
Holocaust that's true
I just asked you to pick some swatches
not that one I like the Holocaust one
why is everything with you is your scale
the Holocaust that's it it doesn't apply
in everyday life I believe it does you
should levels you should have no
Holocaust oh hey by the way
congratulations are in order for a Tim
Tebow yeah
even married former Miss Universe Demi
Lane Elle Peters yeah so what you hear
you hear that parents don't homeschool
your kids or they too might grow up
become a millionaire and bang Miss
Universe the cautionary it starts in the
home you know starts in the home proper
influence your child nobody throws like
this instead of like this okay you sleep
in a racecar exactly
he also played the NFL and Major League
Baseball's Marquette Gerald taking it
seriously mrs. Gerald Morgan Jr was not
the first choice now is Tim Tebow's
saying and let's go to international I
guess Hong Kong Express Airways recently
had to apologize for forcing a passenger
to take a pregnancy test before the
flight I know you think it probably
isn't make any sense it probably won't
but I'll explain it anyway this is from
Sky News many Hong Kong mothers have
actually been traveling to give birth
where their babies can be eligible for
the United States Citizenship and the
woman in question wasn't actually
pregnant
oh no but when she told the airline they
didn't believe her the good news is that
she will still be featured on the cover
of this month's deceptively fat Asians
monthly so she is going beautiful and
brave I want to see even Brendan's
search history for that one I was like
50 percent sure that was gonna be photo
shop you know Asians very slender tip
advice but their leaders are all portly
yes the privileges of winning something
Charles the rich are different alright
so I guess you'd call this entertainment
news and we'll be talking about AOC and
impeachment which I really don't want to
do though you always have to touch an
MP's mention because that's the only
thing the singer I don't feel like I
need to describe Madonna do I need to
say no singer Madonna not really no the
artist formerly known and currently
known as Madonna Madonna's canceled
upcoming tour dates after announcing
that of course she's fallen ill to be Co
doctors say
that it's nothing serious and that soon
Madonna will again be to her old self a
wrinkly old [ __ ] yeah well that's a
clinical outlook it's fairly descriptive
you're right yes I did we send her that
cookie bouquet no I think we said we
send her the cherries berries no [ __ ]
it's an interesting flavor name that
movie line all right finally
KFC now is apologize anyone here know
that no all right that's another
Canadian come no it's DeNiro finally KFC
is apologizing for a recent
advertisement that was accused of being
sexist and we'll give you that one
did someone say cave say wow that one I
understand don't think you have to be a
feminist likes it's a big fan of this
commercial don't believe or not
Julian Castro oh he's just so on message
you know you see politicians they flip
things I know he doesn't I often feel
like politicians are too often trying to
hide the fact that they go stir them to
beezly's right in the middle and we
listed them to peace yeah yeah I think
you have a black y is a lovely love who
correctly answered that I was
psychoanalyze by Jordan Peterson so you
get something in the mail I have no idea
what it is okay so first we have to hit
on impeachment and I'll try and hit this
really quickly because not a whole lot
has changed but there are some processes
that you should probably know about
itself the lot of theater the
impeachment proceedings of course
they've been brought against President
Donald Trump they're continuing last
week after delay from Pelosi the house
managers delivered the articles of
impeachment to the Senate we see the
the impeachment managers now we're going
to bow that that walk to the Senate side
we need to play my leg deliver the
articles from Democrat Leachman it's a
moral dilemma D we got a right one that
he's gonna be roll out this that has
been filled with with rank like cameras
watch Trudeau and I've got real billion
it was apparently directed by Michael
Bay bring shot that goes Nancy's
pantsuit and then I wanted to come up
and then for some reason Ben Affleck's
in it but we don't know what is Lester
Holt what is is he is he biracial he
looks like he looks like a very stylish
muppet that's always what I see no I
spent so much time combing over say like
if Dolce and Gabbana made a muppet yeah
yes it was Lester Holt it's like him I
think he's pretty good at his job but
status Muppet so let me go through the
time line in here which McConnell I
believe I'm not mistaken is released
yeah we have an overlay for impeachment
so 24 hours for opening arguments and
there's going to be 16 to question legal
teams four hours of argument as to
whether bringing in witnesses or not
then there's the vote two-thirds
majority of course are needed that means
twenty Republicans will have to join
forty five Democrats and two
independents to convict now remember in
the house three Democrats voted against
impeachment in one voted present which
means
Lester Holt is Ethiopian they're
surprisingly light yeah they are yeah
a lot of Americans misconstrue
Ethiopians with Kenyans yeah
Ethiopians lighter Kenyans good at
marathons very good and helpful okay so
we've covered impeachment I don't want
you know what I've realized this I'm
pretty much not happy at doing my work
unless I'm either creating or learning
right right and teaching by the way as
well as learning when I have to do
research to go through some of these
meat segments or deep dives as people
call them for you guys I learn as well
so it's exciting impeachment nobody's
learning anything it is political
theater and so people say well why don't
you talk about me I just I just I don't
care there's no news this is what you've
driven us you and me Mia all right so
let's get to actually I think this is
more important because kind of like with
the 2016 campaign
everyone was focusing on Hillary Clinton
and we focused on Bernie you can go back
and watch those videos we have the most
viewed videos on Bernie Sanders in that
2016 period and we thought okay Hillary
Clinton is it's going to be effectively
a coronation right with Hillary Clinton
but Bernie is the movement candidate
that's the one that you have to dissect
and ridicule so that people see the
absurdity for what it is
same thing here if people are just
focusing on Klobuchar or Warren and I
understand their way further left I
think it's important to still recognize
that Bernie and now AOC these are the
movement candidates that you need to be
more concerned with so that thing said
at an event that was commemorating
Martin Luther King jr. yes one of them
nailed the thing to the door of the
church different more than black guy one
Alexandria Castillo Cortez gave an
interview with author tintin the heat
Tunis he see tuna he coached in a he
secret well here you go
yeah another thing that I've been really
thinking and sitting with today is that
we there's this gun rights protest
that's happening down in Richmond and on
MLK Day but here's the image that has
struck him okay let me think about a
time is that when we go out and March
for the dignity and the recognition of
the lives
of people like Freddie gray and Eric
garner the whole no mention of round no
matter portraying a cure without a gun
in sight and here are all of these
people flying Confederate flags with
semi-automatic weapons and there's
almost no police officers at that
protest which by the way I know you're
thinking is this old from last year no
no it's the same MLK event same host and
she's like the Ricky Gervais and I just
did this guy just mhm mhm okay okay
before we get into the facts
some of it is escape do you realize that
the trash didn't come out my trash comes
on Wednesday they have yet to come
because of the holiday of MLK Day what a
second because of MLK Day you can't do
your job on Wednesday they push no I
understand everything MLK jr. stood for
but you know what I'm gonna throw the
baby out with the bathwater because I
have overflowing trash at this point not
I don't even know what to do with
recycling hope you enjoy your voting
rights is it worse than a ball the cost
I'm just checking in uh okay by the way
she says a couple things will get to the
fact that actually she's the guy sits on
MLK Day well as though guns are right
Luther King jr. by the applied for
concealed carry permit to defend himself
and was denied despite qualifying right
MLK was not anti Second Amendment at all
and that should point us to the dangers
of giving over that authority and
autonomy to the government because at
that point the government didn't provide
equal rights to blacks and they had
their justifications well guess what
that can change at any that can change
at any point if the government is in
charge of granting and recognizing
rights as opposed to it being granted by
in greater right so you remember when we
were done doing that changed my mind
it's the exact same reason for people
are like Oh Second Amendment doesn't
apply to me right oh no no big deal I
don't care about guns the same argument
was made with the First Amendment we
would hear from people who would say
well I think the government should
decide what's appropriate to be said or
what's offensive and I said okay great
so you want Trump to decide
no not not that government but that's
exactly the points yeah yeah
we'll kick him out you go to Penn you're
gonna be dipping them back into shock
therapy like a lecture island and that's
when you come down you look at the
second remember you go who do you want
to decide right want the government to
decide who can defend themselves and who
can't at a certain level we know that
there are restrictions under the Second
Amendment right not the kind of
restrictions that are being pushed right
by the left yeah
and it's almost as if you know she
forgets like guys every time you guys
get together in March a town usually
gets lit on fire and nudity so maybe we
need a few more people you guys not know
people getting stupid people like it has
nothing to do with race it's all
stupidity yes exactly and by the way
something else it's also based on a
false premise she said oh and there is
not there all these guns and not Donna
not a police officer and said there were
three different police forces working
overtime and like like like Kajol said
the event was peaceful unlike the black
lives matter protest by the way he/she
didn't mentioned Ferguson hands up don't
shoot start up with Mike Brown yeah
little word of advice don't try to punch
a cop or pistol whip him with his own
gun just first starters so in Ferguson
the end of the cost the city millions of
dollars Dallas 12 officers were shot
five were killed so again which side
would really need more police if their
events not to mention the little fact
that an aunt if a member tried to
firebomb an ice facility after being
inspired by a o'seas concentration camp
rhetoric and want to be really clear
here it was it wasn't like some guy in
Christchurch then mentioning Oh Candice
Owens as a troll job this person
believed that there were concentration
camps going on it's really more like a
pizza gate comparison well looking this
is the same event that it's right before
this right before we played that clip
they were praising the work that was
done in Ferguson and also by antiphon
yeah these two groups on my are you
serious of course we're gonna have
protection from these people what people
again is Duraflame under a Walgreens who
would have known it's like what's it
well what do you what did you what do
you mean no no it's like a it's like a
fire starter like a log rapid I know a
dirt flame is why would you put it under
a wall good and then the gasoline your
cars and that by the way could be a
bordo Rican gentleman no I guess
it's also stupid we don't have a Left
Party in the United States Democratic
Party's not aligned he's just doing that
that's all him which is truly quest or
Center Conservative Party seriously
every time they go to that guy his mouth
is open like this like you know like
Sonny Liston after and anybody's been
how do you go gets that can't go zoom
it's just he's got his own sound board a
second there is no left party the
Democrats Alice meant that their their
moderate do you do you mean like do you
mean on immigration where you guys are
for reasonable immigration reform border
security oh no wait a second you are for
not only completely open borders and no
wall but against not deporting we're not
talking bout dreamers or children you
are against deporting cereal violent
felons provided that they currently live
in sanctuary cities and you're against
sending back criminals who are in our
prisons illegally oh okay well you must
mean that Democrats are what they're
more moderate on abortion say for things
like limitations that most Americans
even who identify as pro-choice like 20
week limits I don't know maybe the first
trip wait no you mean the entire
democratic party with the exception of
Tulsi Gabbard support abortion up until
the baby crowns oh my gosh so I don't
know maybe the Democrat let me take
their centrist on firearms right where
maybe they're just talking about making
sure that violent felons don't get
firearms and wit no hon that's already
the case oh no you're talking about the
dissenting opinions in Heller versus DC
in the entire Democratic Party who want
to make all semi-automatic firearms
illegal what do you pull us like maybe
what you mean Democrats are moderate on
taxes and I believe in a progressive tax
code where I don't know maybe like 37
percent in the top bracket or maybe our
corporate tax should be comparable to
other nations like Sweden oh no wait
you're okay with a 90 percent tax and
you want us to have the highest
corporate tax in the industrialized
world I just I think there's a
disconnect you crazy horrible human
being very sound sound senator
conservative yeah very very
they were just talking about their in
that clip right before it too that you
you can't she's like I don't believe
that you can capitalism your way out of
these problems we have to get
medicare-for-all onto the floor for at
least a vote we need to be able to do
them like that's not a centrist policy
yeah to get right everybody might it be
fantastic give every American a million
dollars right now that would probably be
better off but we would also be broke I
don't know so don't you bring your info
on my show without a reference that's
true well I do look I do like the fact
you remember she was kind of lambasted
for the amount she spent on Hoover black
SUVs pain yeah sounds like capitalism
did did are bad yeah well we go there
what through abortion guns taxes
immigration I would now say what okay
story that's not told is the impact on
our collective psyche hmm on the island
like the turtle humping a word food
treats them as treats us as full
citizens because we you know I states
doesn't you know my own family it's like
they had all of these emergency
backpacks ready to go and rations
because they knew that no one was gonna
come and and to know that a society does
not care for you has a profound impact
on one psyche nobody talked about
ascribing intent yeah so not only did
she just describe motive and intent
knowing they don't care about you but
then also attributed non-existent policy
to it or actually this goes back lest
you you have forgotten all the way back
to 2017 with San Juan mayor
it was claiming that Trump was
withholding relief aid I don't have you
guys remember that but if you recall
actually it was the mayor who hadn't
attended any meetings in Puerto Rican
officials had they completely failed to
coordinate delivery the supplies so even
those that they had received remained
completely unopened look in that that
picture right there
that's a press conference in front of
unopened supply boxes that's like Donkey
Kong country's banana horn where where
whatever could these supplies be right
so it must be because Americans Porto
Rican of course and they the supplies
actually set so long that some of them
you couldn't be used anymore oh yeah
because they didn't distribute there
right well now okay so with the recent
earthquake this is officer atomic
thoughts and prayers at the people of
Puerto Rico of course
Puerto Rican government has repeated the
same cycle with loads of supplies
remaining in warehouses not being
distributed to those in need I guess
then America it's American fault
51st state fingers crossed
Jose was down there right she was the
one finding the warehouse that yes you
Bart ended in Brooklyn for like three
decades since she was one early start
oh my gosh came out suckling on a bottle
of Jack I think what one of the problems
that we see in cases like this it's much
more fashionable and politically
expedient to bash Trump and say that
this this people group is against you
yeah it is to actually go out and do the
work of distributing some well no I
think what's really important here and
yes you're right but the problem with
Puerto Rico is not the United States
it's not our conservatism it's not free
enterprise it is the bloated
bureaucratic government that you a OSI
view is the solution to all problems
when you talk about taking out big
businesses when you talk about fair
distribution when you talk about more
centralized regulation who are you
talking about the exact kind of people
government officials mayors governors so
I don't know the entire maybe it's a
part Porto Rico I don't know it's that
no it is i know important people the
point is you want them to be in charge
of these disasters exclusively you want
them to be in charge of medical aid
that's also why you want to take away
tax exempt status from churches who by
the way provide an overwhelming amount
of relief to a lot of these foreign
countries we did it here with a
hurricane RV at one point they don't
want to say because by the way unless
you forget the argument is we just did
that so it's a tax deduction right right
right yeah we raised several hundred
thousand dollars for hurricane harvey
because we would pay a few thousand
dollars left in taxes you [ __ ] you
googly eyes demon
that's a new one so sorry I always
wonder about those arguments because
then it's the argument that we should
discourage charitable donations by
taking away that small tiny yes de
minimis incentive yes is that's gonna
encourage more ideas take it away so
that they can sit on the supplies but I
thought the government was the one that
wasn't sending the aid correctly that's
just because you were raised in the air
okay don't think confusing for you it is
it's confusing yeah it is mine is still
always Tiananmen Square he divert back
alway it is but he's rooting for the bad
guy who's unfortunately he's saying
full-speed ahead in the tank it's like
payback with Mel Gibson right he wants
the bad guy to win all right a
notification bell and hit all
notifications on the Bell if you've hit
the notification bell before and you're
subscribed because now apparently the
notification bell does not alert you of
all uploads or the live streams new
video goes up every single night with
the exception of Sunday and of course
join mug Club lotos Peter calm slash mug
Club because that is what allows us to
continue to produce this content for you
and like 80% more content there in the
entire blaze TV catalog alright I think
we have more of this this broad next
clip
sat on a couch maybe a lot see thousands
maybe nice sectional a fainting couch
modern-day slave wages and in some cases
we always real modern-day slavery
depending on where you are in our in
terms of food production not in this
country made that money off the backs of
undocumented people
you made that money off of the backs of
black and brown people being paid off a
living wage under a living wage earned
that money off of the backs of single
mothers single mothers and all of these
people who are literally dying because
they can't afford to live and so know
what I like her hype man couch is with
the joke's on you I was in a day bed
it's it's Americans exploiting black and
brown people paying them slave wages
let me ask how about the brown people
paying brown people going rate
sweetheart let's get a fair trade bull
I'm sure this thing bothered me so much
you see some people talk about like like
coffee or whatever it is if they're
buying at the store cacao which is a
stupid term it's cocoa it's cocoa it's
cocoa you just haven't roasted it
stop saying to cow it doesn't change
what it is going and so you see this
fair trade label on there what happens
they tell you a story right they go well
it's fair trade because if you don't pay
fair trade these people in these
countries we don't realize they're being
exploited and they're only making a
dollar a day and you don't ask them well
what do they make with your fair trade
cocoa about a buck fifty further there
they don't provide the context for
example I think we have a source your
ivory coast agricultural workers make on
average four dollars a day those who
work for Fairtrade certified companies
see it posted to a whopping six ooh
so they're not someone's paid an
American minimum wage you need to
provide the scale and the context and on
top of that this goes back to AO sees
false claimed with the living wage
claims which doesn't really mean
anything because it changes every single
year yes they were debunked by
Washington Post last year let's do you
think that it's fake news the company of
course that Alexandria Cascio Nina Pinta
Santa Maria Cortez
one that she always takes a Mattia is
amazon for not paying its employees evil
living wage he's evil billionaires right
they didn't make these companies they
just sat on their what was it of
loveseat they just they just really
pretty much they sat on their beanbag
didn't make these companies where there
are now hundreds of thousands of people
who have jobs right Amazon alone
employed 750,000 people in 2019 that's
sounds like a lot and you want to know
what AOC would do what she's talking
about this if someone like her so it's
not necessarily about AOC because she
probably won't make it to some kind of
serious national platform as far as
presidents or something like that
because she's crazy you can see the what
are you calling a squirrel okay turn the
horse degree dropped yeah do you want to
know what someone like AOC would do if
they were in power nationally if they
about Donald Trump and one of the most
burning economies that we've ever seen
look at her district in New York where
she gave Amazon the boot despite the
overwhelming support of her constituents
wanting to bring Amazon in along with
its twenty five thousand jobs below a
living wage mind you 150 thousand
dollars average annual salary yeah
that's more than so she's for the
workers yeah we should just toss that to
AOC think about that for a second twenty
five thousand jobs yeah in Queens gone
one hundred fifty thousand dollars a
year right the point is if you just if
you think that that's exploitation you
just hate companies that aren't
government-owned you want to nationalize
everything don't tell me that it's about
sixteen dollars an hour don't even tell
me it's about twenty five dollars an
hour right you kicked out 25,000 jobs
averaging one hundred and fifty thousand
dollars a year it's it that's over
you're done nobody likes lying losers
with crazy eyes next clip I think it's
totally fine and human and natural to
feel that way so my joints are okay I
think you're okay
good to see you priorities are straight
like living it while fighting for a
better world the same nike famous for
exploiting sweatshop labor conditions in
other countries that we don't allow with
our capitalist system by the way here in
the united states but it's ok when it's
night because they support sodomy and
this ass so that's fine what is it with
the eyes and these people i don't know
not these pain like the color again
sponsored sure what are you looking for
they're a keeper nick fruit free
jordan's like once a quarter put you on
a poster at Dick's Sporting Goods who
think you know what I do find
interesting is remember when she talks
about you know on the backs of black and
brown workers who are not paid a living
wage right you notice she's not
concerned about anyone besides a
minority right there's not worry about
yeah white workers who may also be
exploited but here's the other part is
the message here don't hire single moms
is the message here yeah don't hire
minorities no of course not the idea
that these companies aren't also
contributing so if she saying that all
the social media companies that are
making billions of dollars they're the
ones that are the problem we should
break them up and not allow them to have
the control maybe angry drunk no I'm a
little confused honestly the Nike thing
threw me for a loop
it really is it's it seemed like quite
the contradiction yeah it doesn't really
make a whole lot of sense to me it seems
as though it's nonsensical I think we
have is just the last clip of aoc answer
thank you yes to be ethical if you're a
billionaire today the thing that you
need to do is give up control and power
and you're sick I don't want money as
much as we want your power we don't want
as you learned in write a billionaire to
fund this or that but we want to demand
is to change these systems change the
business model that has exploited so
many people huh I wasn't looking at my
iPad I just honest I was just looking
down because I'm very sad it's
embarrassing for her we want your power
I don't really
okay so someone should make a company
produce something employ people add
value and then you oh so you'll steal it
right Steven you're misunderstanding
billionaires as she stated before never
make a billion dollars they they hate
they take that's not taking no it's not
tonight a Google is into the mix former
key on the rule book yes
idea of why that is horrible Jeff Bezos
I don't agree with his politics we've
talked about that quite a bit
but he's not some guy who was raised
wealthy with the silver dollars Murray
this is a guy this is the American dream
created it less like keep saying lest I
should stop it's good Lester Holt that's
not a funny money we have to bring that
back up he was like a stylish Muppet
says in case you've forgotten Amazon was
a book seller for a long time it didn't
become what it is today accidentally I
don't agree with his politics but what
gives me the right to take anything from
just bait Jeff Bezos this is this is the
concept they want to take from people
aoc who've actually worked to create
something it would be to give you a more
kind of direct comparison I think I was
talking with our researcher reg who's
brilliant just and he's so strong he
squats like six hundred thirty pounds
like it competitive power later at 180
pound body weight I said imagine this if
we could put on just sort of this these
helmets like I think you've seen them in
Star Trek where you switch bodies and
you've done all of this work and for
eight years you worked to create this
total so you can compete on a national
level and powerlifting and all of a
sudden I just go and I suck up your
power because here's the thing she's
talking about giving us your power well
we see with Puerto Rico or the
government even the United States they
don't give up the power once they've
taken it the power is going somewhere
you are talking aoc about displacing
power from people who are beholden to
adding value lest they lose power I said
it again versus you who will have the
power subsequently regardless of having
earned it and we should know this anyone
who has a serious fire I'm a high
caliber firearm and has never used it
never trained with it that's a bad idea
put someone under a five hundred pound
barbell who's never worked their way up
to create that strength it doesn't end
well these people who want all of the
or she just said haven't earned it it
will collapse and they will fold under
the weight and subsequently the American
people and understand why if someone had
to work to create this let's even go
back to Jeff bezels I don't know those
politics why is it immoral for mr. Bezos
to want to keep what he's created but
it's not immoral for you or me to want
to take it again displacing this power
from billionaires you're going to
displace it to people who made porto
rico happen and you know to people i
just it's this let's go through this
personally yeah here i guess this is
what you want to say give up the power
and i'm not a billionaire but this
company would be in the same tax bracket
that something that people don't tell
you okay so no matter what i did by the
way not taking a paycheck not taking us
out or not being paid a dime for this
show for two three four five years
building it up sleepless nights running
it out of my den then an old massage
parlor in case you rented this office
now I get why the rent was low to move
to a new office we went from one
employee to three employees to five
employees now to 15 employees who all
make by the way significantly above a
living wage but because this was
successful because I built something
that actually adds value it's it's
inherently immoral okay I understand
that you know what up I get it
I am going to give up the power and you
know what quote about Garrett I'm gonna
give them I'm gonna give the power to
you to you yep all you have to do is
touch that button and that power is no
longer mine
chuckling coming up
[Music]
our world is increasingly ruled by
technology information moves faster than
the speed of light but how do you know
that you and your personal information
are safe that's why you should protect
yourself with the latest in cyber
security technology a sticky note are
you worried that it might leave you open
to hackers spies geo blocks IP detection
ad targeting NSA habit tracking traffic
logs third-party microphone access and
theft of your personal data we've got
you covered with a sticky note and if
you're concerned about all that other
stuff
there's always expressvpn obviously if
you're a fan of the show you spend a lot
of time online but every time you open a
browser you may not know this I didn't
because I was a technology idiot I was
like Mike you know my grandmother with a
giant V share with a giant blue buttons
it was me and even it was a VCR with a
giant blue buttons I still don't know
how to work it little as TiVo still a
thing
the point is online you're leaving
yourself open to hackers IP detection
targeting could be the NSA Russians we
have no idea but what you do online
should be your business and your
business only that's why everyone here
uses expressvpn we actually use it when
we've done some searches I believe with
tulsi gabbard to look at algorithms and
and test it with different locations it
has I mean it encrypts everything 100%
of your data is safe the software takes
about a minute to set up on your
computer your phone really easy to use
if you go to expressvpn comm /s crowder
right now sign up get an extra three
months of express VPN service for free
and also really important they didn't
have any kind of a data breach as some
competing VPNs did and didn't tell you
about so good track record the balls to
sponsor the show and you should be using
a VPN please consider using expressvpn
just for us VPN comes Lashkar adder and
now a reading from the democratic
socialist manifesto with comrade
Cortese's unfit any longer to be the
ruling class
Squad is the ruling class now we run
this me a girl Ilhan Rasheeda and I
never learned the other girl's name it
doesn't matter
we're coming for you Israel join mug
club because soon videos like this will
be all that's left on YouTube oh hi seen
on the board do you guys have black
rifle coffee here no I'm sorry we only
carry good small batch coffee here well
it is great small batch coffee
well that really can't be unless it's
fresh roasted some you know what is
fresh versus oh thank you know what that
means you know what this is this is
masala quoi PK which of course in the
Indonesian Maya let me finish and the
Indonesian language it's weasel coffee
you just made that up no it's been past
their digestive tract that's discussed
and then it's nature's what processing
yeah is it good
I mean it's alright are they investor
philanthropist today support good causes
yeah that's a causal veterans causes and
your first responder causes but it
doesn't matter because they make good
coffee so that's what I'm wondering do
you have any you know what actually I'm
I'm just gonna order it let me get fresh
roasted black rifle coffee it's good
black rifle coffee by the way if you go
to black rifle coffee calm / crowd are
you entering the promo code Crider
you'll get 20% off your first order and
we over ordered by the width of the kids
book who put the pepper in the pot where
everyone thinks the other person put the
pepper in the pot and so they all put
pepper in the pot and then the pot is
just too hot because there's so much
pepper the point is we're gonna have
like 30 pounds of coffee because
everyone here double ordered will be
giving some away comment below why you
love coffee how you like your coffee and
listen black rifle coffee
they are veteran-owned a portion of
their profits go to veteran veteran
organizations and that's all great but
here's the thing they make better coffee
than the competition so just give it a
try and they fresh roast it that's
really important by the way a lot of
people don't know coffee is a bean it's
perishable after about a month it goes
bad so black rifle roasts to order as
soon as you order the coffee
I love the the vintage roast the green
bag the coffee saves go to black rifle
calm slash Crowder entering the promo
code and if you drink coffee might as
well drink better coffee that supports
good causes
[Music]
okay well chipper up because I will tell
you this our next guest is usually very
serious very stoic very stone face stoic
you know I guess I would go back to a
Marcus Aurelius
I have no I have absolutely no idea the
point is you're very chipper before we
came on air which that's true makes me
think he's done he's used to me illicit
substances you know and you love them
you can follow of course Jocko will Inc
on the Twitter Jacko podcast calm I do
not have his newest book yet but it is
leadership strategy and tactics a Field
Manual in origin USA yeah as a
supplement company they do all kinds of
American closing now I hope I've gotten
all those in correctly mister willing
how are you sir I am doing outstanding
thank you for having me back on your
program thank you very much it why so
formal what does that mean first off you
say here's the thing you're such a
you're such a deadly guy but that
sounded so [ __ ] on your program Mean
Girls it's just your whole intro thing
kind of made me say to myself alright
he's taking herself way too seriously
let's just attack him out of the game
yeah that's absolutely fine it'd be like
when you're rolling and right away you
just snatch a comer and crank it for
dear life no all right we'll talk about
that during the break a little bit some
some stores in that because of course
people who don't know chuckling not only
highly decorated military background but
it accomplished a jiu-jitsu fighter as
well all right so first off tell us
about your new book which you did not
send to me and how it differs from these
you know what let's just we'll put in
digitally the new book yeah differ from
the previous books because I've read
them and I will have one of my producers
here as a huge fan he's read everything
but obviously you know you read one
leadership book you think like I got to
figure it out
yeah well unfortunately that's what
people think all too often and so here's
the deal I have the have the leadership
consulting company echelon front I go
around all the time talking about
leadership talking to companies talking
to business leaders I have a podcast
where I talk about leadership all the
time and I take questions in both those
situations I take questions from people
I would get asked the same questions
over and over and over again and what I
realized is that people might understand
the principles but they're not quite
sure of how to actually apply them and
so I would get asked the questions why I
took all those questions down over the
years and I eventually wrote down all
the leadership strategy and tactics that
I used wrote them down in a book so
people couldn't open up a book see the
problem that they have and then find a
solution to that problem so it's very
granular you know it's called a field
manual the reason it's called a field
mint field manuals in the military
there's field manuals for just about
everything that you do for having shoot
a gun for how you clean a gun for how
you use a compass there's a field manual
for everything they're very simple very
straightforward step-by-step that's what
this is it's for leadership and it's
simple straightforward step-by-step how
to improve your leadership capabilities
well let me ask you this because you say
that you've gotten a lot of questions
and I ask this because your books are
pretty clear I mean they're pretty
in-depth the ones that I've read before
so do you find especially being seen as
someone who's relatively intense I don't
think I'm speaking out of turn are
people afraid to ask you questions in
real life do they feel are they worried
that it might be a stupid question and
how do you usually react someone like
you who's been specific in your
instruction what kind of questions come
back to you
get questions all the time okay so the
first book called extreme ownership you
know someone might say the premise is if
you make a mistake or if a mission fails
or a project fails then you actually
take ownership of it so I'd get this
question all the time they'd say hey hey
Jocko what if I take ownership of the
problem and I say it's my fault and then
the team looks at me and they say yeah
you're right it is your fault what do i
do then you shoot them so I know
actually there's myth what you say to
the team is uh yes I just said it was my
fault and now you're saying it's my
fault that's what I said it actually is
my fault I'm taking ownership of the
problem and these are the things I'm
going to do to make sure that we get
this problem solved and it doesn't
happen again
because what happens is when people say
you know what this was my fault
I take ownership of it they think now
okay cool now I get a free pass because
I said it's my fault right well that's
not the reality you you still have to
take ownership of the problem you have
to figure out what the solution is and
you have to implement that solution so
those are the kind of things that I
answer these questions all the time and
I put them all in this book how do you
deal with someone that has a negative
attitude on your team what do you do
with them how do you deal with rumors
running rampant just all those problems
that people experience in leadership
positions I tackle yeah well what what
happens um if everyone says it's their
fault if it's like I am you know I'm
Spartacus but I'm just like I'm a [ __ ]
I screwed up I mean well you know whose
fault is it yeah what happens is what
you end up with is interlocking fields
of fire so so what that means is on the
battlefield yeah you and I are supposed
to cover an area well we don't we don't
take one little section and say okay
everything to the right of that I'll
cover everything that left of that you
cover no we actually say we open it up
so we have a little bit of overlap yes
it wouldn't on a team when multiple
people are saying well okay the supplies
didn't get here on time and the supply
person says yeah you know what I didn't
set up the logistics right and then me I
say you know what you didn't set up the
logistics are it's actually my fault
because I didn't order the materials
early enough yeah well now what we both
do is now I start ordering them earlier
and the supply person starts cleaning
out the logistics train and now that
problem is solved from two different
directions so it's never going to happen
again
so yes when you're on a team and people
start taking ownership everyone will
take ownership it's awesome
it'll all get the problem solved but
sometimes it's awkward if you say I
didn't get the logistics right and the
other guys just saying yeah should have
done that then it's even less
comfortable
well that's the thing is and what what
kicks in is people's ego when they go I
didn't get the logistics right and they
want people to go no no no no you did
great no no people like oh yeah yeah you
actually didn't get them right because
that's why it took so long
me and then their ego goes wait a second
wasn't my fault I should have well
actually it was your fault that's the
thing about extreme ownership extreme
ownership isn't just lip service like
well if I say it's my fault
everyone will ignore me and give me a
pass that's not what happens
it shouldn't happen that way so it
sounds like this this book could I mean
part of it could be substituted with
just being married you say it's my fault
your wife says absolutely and then you
go on your merry way and avoid making
her cross so people people align these
things I know you said it joking around
cuz you're the comedian and all this
stuff you're supposed to be funny I
don't have the cleft okay yeah so people
people bring it up all the time though
how does this stuff apply to marriage
and yeah it absolutely apprise you
emerge so when your wife says oh no one
took out the garbage you didn't take out
the garbage this morning on Monday so
now it's gonna be sitting in the alley
for another week instead of being like
well you should have told me you should
remind you is Monday know you say you
know what it's my fault oh actually from
now on I'm gonna put a reminder on my
calendar so I remember yeah and your
wife goes good yeah and you said now you
don't let your ego get involved you
actually take ownership for the problem
and now from now on you get the garbage
out on time you don't have a stinky
alleyway so it actually works and your
relationship will be better with your
wife except for when it's near a holiday
and they switch the trash day and then
one have to kill the trash man that's
what happened New Year's that's why I've
still been laying lover let you know
look mrs. and I want to get to sort of
don't you don't you have neighbors well
actually my neighbor went through my
mail which is a federal crime so we
don't talk much anymore
you could always impose your your
garbage on your on your neighbor's trash
can if it's really state this is true
I had a very old neighbor who lives in
the house with the lights off and all he
doesn't come out to trim his bushes and
sort through my mail and I said hey I
loved it wasn't malicious I said great I
appreciate it but just because if we're
gone for a long weekend you don't go
through my mail that's not how this
works you know that's a true story
let's bring in he's like hey your mail
was in so-and-so's mailbox again I want
to get to a sort of Iran and Seoul may
knee a little bit because you have some
insight there that I'd like to kind of
sort of I guess I guess what's the word
I'm looking for I don't know I had a
stroke but before that you know right
now we have an incredible economy that's
been really doing well the last years
but we also have 1,300 CEOs who stepped
down in the past year and as someone who
works with a lot of CEOs and people in
positions of power
executive power particularly with
businesses why do you think that is it's
something that I haven't necessarily
been able to figure out well when
companies doing bad the then that blame
is gonna shift to the CEO which is where
it should shift you know when a company
where a team is not doing well it's the
leaders fault and if the leader doesn't
do things to reverse that course and get
things on track yeah they're gonna feel
a lot of pressure to step down that's
that's what's gonna happen
and I've seen it over and over again
when you have a bad team a bad group a
bad company you can change out that
leader and absolutely turn things around
almost immediately I used to see that
with CEO person it's occasionally we
would fire a seal platoon leader because
of because and we're firing the seal
platoon leader because the seal platoon
is performing badly right we would find
that guy bringing a new leader would
usually find a leader that had some
experience that was a good leader put
him in there I'm not kidding the next
mission they would go on next training
mission everything would be smooth and
that that's the impact of leadership of
good leadership so when you see a
company that's not doing what they're
supposed to be doing they're not
performing well that the eventually the
board or the the chairman of the board
or the investors are gonna turn that guy
and say yeah we don't want you anymore
yeah we can call it stepping down but
they're getting fired oh is that what it
because I'm gonna say it's it's that
would apply if the economy were doing
poorly or these companies are doing
poorly but if you look into it some of
these companies are doing doing pretty
well like most companies are right now
and CEOs are stepping down but you think
that a lot of that is maybe
stepping down well I mean you know you
might also have people that have done
enough and they've grinded it out for 18
years and they're gonna take some time I
mean I don't know what particular cases
that you're talking about maybe it is
people that are just ready to step down
and enjoy some other part of the life
that's the possibility - I'm talking
broadly when I deal with companies and
the CEO leaves generally generally it's
because the CEO and the company is doing
poorly and the company's doing poorly
because the CEO is not leading well and
that's actually the I only work with
most of the companies that we work with
that I salon founder are companies that
are doing well right and the reason that
they're doing well is because they're
humble and that's why they're coming to
us asking for help
because they want to improve their
leadership and they're humble enough to
ask for leadership when we work with
companies that are not doing well we
show up there that board the board tells
us to go and talk to the company the
board wants us to help them we show up
there and of course they're the CEO and
the leadership team saying we don't
actually need your help we're doing
great it's just that the markets bad and
the competitor did this and the union
said that and that's why we're failing
but it has nothing to do with us yeah or
like my neighbor steals my mail he
always just blames it on the Mexicans
every time which I just said knowing why
don't I understand I know the guy who
does your pool his name is let me ask
you before I actually want to ask you
one question on that and then get to
your tours in Iraq and then bring in our
producer but you said you touched on
something there which i think is
important I've had a lot of fighters on
the show we've talked about this you
said some CEOs just realize it's their
time to step down and they want to move
on to another part of their life listen
you're an intense guy you've obviously
be accomplished a lot in the military
now you're accomplishing a lot in the
business world but you're you know you
get up at 4:45 you do it by choice I
have problems sleeping so I'm always up
at 4:00 but I also understand that this
is not a pace that I've been maintained
for last couple years I can do forever
sometimes the people who are in
positions of leadership are the last to
know that it's maybe time for them to
take on a different role and it's not
because they're incapable but it's
because maybe they're in a different
stage of their life and I ask this
because a lot of Fighters are the last
to know that they should stop fighting
how do you think people who are
successful and disciplined and intense
how do they recognize that it's their
time to move on and how do you think
you'll ever have to make that decision
you know yourself because yeah you're
but at some point you're gonna get old
and and and you went gray young so it
works for you but that's not gonna be
there forever
you mean I'm not gonna be gray forever
you're gonna have nothing therefore it's
gonna be Dick Cheney in about eight
years it's just an Instagram app I think
for people I think a lot of people that
that have my type of attitude I mean I'm
always looking for something new to do
right it's not like I want to stay and
do the same thing over and over again so
I think for me I'll be looking around
going okay this this this felt pretty
good let me turn this over to the
someone else and move on move on to some
other challenge so it's about do you
think a big part of that's feeling
confident in sort of handing it off to
someone who's capable and that's why
it's so important maybe to build up new
leaders yeah we used to say we always
want to work ourselves out of a job so I
want my the two platoon commanders that
are working for me I want them to both
be able to step up and take my job and
do a better job than me Rach means then
I can move on to the next level yeah I
think that's a good way to look at it um
let me ask you a stringer your two tours
I believe you did too right in Iraq yeah
I'm not mistaken um you know soul mania
was obviously it recently the news what
is your opinion on that situation in
sort of the Irani influence on the war
with your direct experience yeah so with
my direct experience especially my
second deployment when the Iranians were
so this is now 2006 I was in Ramadi
which is in western Iraq it's a I stated
Ramadi in Albuquerque once that is not
pleasant yeah I moved on down to the
Hacienda so yeah well the Ramadi and
that I was in was not very nice either
probably comparable it was a Sunni area
so there wasn't a huge Shia influence
other than the military the Iraqi
military was mostly Shia soldiers
Scioscia sold soldiers coming into
Ramadi with us working amongst the Sunni
populace fighting against a
predominantly Sunni insurgency in that
area so as far as the Iranian influence
there it was less however during that
time and increasingly through 2007 2008
2009
the Iranian influence increased a lot
especially in and around Baghdad there's
a place called Sadr City you know it's
it's an awful place and that is and all
over you know Baghdad surrounding areas
the the Iranian influence was making
these these IEDs which are called EF PS
which means explosively formed
projectile and where a normal ID would
not penetrate the skin of a tank or of
an armored personnel carrier those EF PS
would absolutely they would penetrate
the armor and they would kill everyone
inside or kill or wound people inside
and these the Iranians sulamani were
they were specifically manufacturing
these shipping them to Iran teaching
people how to emplace them properly and
he was accountable for the deaths of I
don't know what no I think they say 600
Americans but it's hundreds and hundreds
and hundreds of Americans this is an
evil human being that needed to die and
I'm glad he's dead well and I know that
you've said that so how would you and I
know you often avoid so we're speaking
on politics directly which which I
appreciate because you're in a position
of leadership where you can influence
people of all stripes but how would you
sort of respond or what's your reaction
to a lot in the media and some on
certain sides of the political aisle
right now portraying so many is kind of
a respected irani military official and
and a lot of people have condemned
President Trump for the action he took
so there's a couple things that I've
said first of all he was not just an
enemy solo mania was not just an enemy
of American troops in America
he's an enemy of his own people of the
Iranian people this is a guy they've
killed and again you don't know what the
real numbers are but in the neighborhood
of a thousand maybe more maybe less
protesters people that are standing up
against the Iranian regime had been
killed in the last six months this the
Iranian people do not want this regime
in power and and so when he gets killed
what did we see we saw the Iranians
rising up in the streets and and the
protests against the downing of the
Turkish airline once again that they
immediately lied about kind of change
their story but the Iranians don't want
this group in power right so we killed
someone that's an enemy to
Americans and an enemy to the Iranian
people and you know one of the other
things that I said was I said that this
was a gamble yeah that took a gamble and
okay maybe maybe that's not the right
word choice and maybe I should have
explained it for some people that were
looking to pounce on everything that
somebody says that's positive about
president I thought it is a good word
choice I will say I would I would defend
it because I think you're right hey
listen and I think most people don't
understand that's the leadership
language people in positions of
leadership you're always somewhat making
a gamble you're trying to make as
educated of a bet as possible because a
lot of people don't know this if you're
handed sort of a handbook from an
employer or from someone who's leading
like you said this your platoon you have
your instructions you know what you have
to follow you have very clear guidelines
as to what is the metric for success and
what would be failure for in a position
of leadership it is always a little bit
of a gamble because you're setting those
standards yourself so I would say don't
walk it back but I appreciate your
candor yeah so I guess I'm not walking
it back but maybe a better word to use
would be hey it's a risky move it's it
there is risk and then and what I said
was hey it's kind of what you just said
when you conduct a military operation I
don't care what it is there's gonna be
risk involved there's a gamble and the
other example that I used was Obama
getting bin Laden Obama gave the order
to go into a sovereign country without
telling that military that we're gonna
go in there and kill someone that was
there that's what we did that is a
massive gamble and guess what that
gamble paid off it was successful we're
all overjoyed that Osama bin Laden is
dead and I remember some people on the
right when when that happened and they
said yeah Obama killed Osama bin Laden
people said it wasn't Obama it was the
seals I get it but it was actually Obama
that gave the order and that was a huge
gamble for him to take and it turned out
to be very positive I'm happy that it
happened of course right Soleimani very
similar this was a big gamble for Trump
to take I would say maybe not as big of
a gamble in some ways because he didn't
really risk any American lives but
everyone America has been so scared
about what the reaction of the Iranian
regime would be for
years we've been nervous about it and he
said okay well we're gonna find out and
he did it and that reaction was to throw
some some missiles into the middle of
desert and say yup we're not doing
anything else we're good and that's and
then you got to see that regime getting
turmoil against them back in around so
overall a very positive result and
wasn't a gamble yes could the Iranians
have done some crazy attack back or a
series of attacks sure they could have
they haven't they didn't what making
your talk about a tactical retaliation
but I think we're pretty clear in the
fact that as far as the the moral
conundrum that's been presented that it
it was and it wasn't really a gamble as
far as is he is he not a good guy but
hey before we go wouldn't it have been
cool we're talking about gamble because
it's always a roll of the dice if
someone right before they they shot
Osama bin Laden said oh we rolled the
dice
it came up six SEAL Team six BAM that's
a die-hard sequel I'd see alright listen
I will say this before we go the book of
course is author sorry the author the
author of the book is jock aware link it
is leadership strategy and tactics a
Field Manual I have a producer here for
people who are watching on youtube we
are going to go to a web extended if you
are not a member of Mudd Club smooth
Manny who hails from Colombia is
obsessed with Jaco will link man are you
nervous
dry mouth you're a little bit dry mouth
you need some water and we have Jack
Oatey here Jack oh sure Jack I'll warn
you it's borderline creepy I think he
has a hair puppet somewhere alright
we're gonna go to what extended that's
Jack oh podcast comm stay tuned
[Music]
what's your home defense plan when it
comes to safety there's no substitute
for a quality firearm and if you're a
gun owner there's no replacement for
firearms legal protection firearms legal
protection provides lawful gun owners an
uncapped legal defense program 24/7
emergency hotline access to a network of
over 2,500 experienced attorneys legal
education on firearm laws in your state
via our mobile app and plans to protect
you every step of the way if you are
involved in a self-defense and visit
firearms legal comm /lw see today
um what a complete disaster
excuse me did you just blow in from
dress like a spaz Ville how do you walk
around looking like that
oh yes there you go now you're ready to
fight the man in style louder with
crowder merch makes these two slobs look
better get your ladder with crowder gear
at louder with prouder shop comm and
cover your disgusting body
[Music]
Oh
leave it Oh gross okay good
go get it so the reason I was kind of
showing that as awkward is it okay Betty
come here come here
a lot of you haven't seen Betty a ton
obviously since the hopper said come on
baby okay come on look oh she's pulled
me off my feet a few times come on leave
it leave it okay good go get it thing I
love about this this breed of dog - I
was talking with Jaco about this and I
thought it was relevant to today's sort
of you know I'll come back here so you
guys can see me a little more clearly
all right Betty I'll be back in a second
talking with Jocko you know a lot of
times sort of comes up this topic of
strengths or what it is to be a man and
what I love about these dogs Betty is
coming up on close to hundred pounds we
had it with hopper as well is a dog that
is very capable but controls it you see
that with Betty it's very important that
we train Betty properly the same thing
with hopper because we all live by
Betty's mercy I told that to court a
black gear like we're really fortunate
that she didn't just rip one of our
limbs off or our face like a chimpanzee
I'm xanax and red wine with a clicker
might be a dated reference um but
there's something to be said for and I
think this is the way you should live
for bridled strength and and that's
really important I think people sort of
misconstrue folks like like Jocko or
like Jordan Peterson or myself when I
talk about the importance of masculinity
the importance of being a good man and a
strong man and I think a lot of people
misinterpret this idea of meekness
meekness really and I think Jordan
Peterson has talked about this means
being incredibly capable with a sword
for example but keeping it shaved and
not using it unless you have to for
example right there Betty could
absolutely tear my hand off if she so
wanted but she lets it go because I
request her to and I nurse that's
because it's a relationship of authority
and Submission one that's appropriate
here's the thing um
you can't bridle strengths that you
don't have to begin with so when I talk
about strength and when I talk about how
important that is when I talk about
bridle strength what I am saying is and
I've told
before you know if you want to have
self-confidence do you know what you do
get really really good at something
that's it
there's nothing else that can replace
true self-esteem you can you can ban red
pens all you want so all of your tests
are are corrected with blue markers and
you never get an F you can equalize all
soccer scores all you want you're
entirely you're never going to have
self-esteem until you get really really
good at something and you're never going
to be strong and I don't just mean
physically though I think that's
important too you'll never be strong or
excellent at everything or anything if
you don't work at it day after day and
put in the reps and grind it out for
measurable progress and you know what's
so sad about that what's really sad this
goes back to the idea of bridled
strength which i think is the only way
to live but I mean I'm speaking to men
mainly because that's what I know is it
people who never get excellent at
anything people who never get strong
they never have the opportunity to
bridle it they'll never know what it
feels like to be incredibly capable but
also in control and not have to use that
each Betty just not tapped the caravan
bridle it Betty bridle it you you silly
little [ __ ]
it's okay I can say something a little
[ __ ] I know it's kind of gross I don't
necessarily anticipate her to lick my
face but I do want you to do this drill
here today I want you to think of an
area where you're excellent I want you
to think of an area where you might be
an expert where you might be more
capable that at least most in your life
for some of you maybe that could be
science for some of you maybe that could
be physical strength for somebody it
could be a sport for some of you it
could be political knowledge what I want
you to do is find an area where you are
more capable than other people this week
and not lord it over anyone in other
words find an area where you know you
could score points find an area where
you know you would be top dog and
instead make somebody else feel like
they're the most capable make somebody
else feel like they're the smartest
person in the room what I want you to do
is bridle that strength and and know
what that feels like because that
provides a confidence that cannot be
mimicked any other way and the reason I
also want you to do this is because some
people out there
you may not be able to do this because
you may not find an area in which you're
more excellent than your peers what does
that tell you that tells you there's
there's some other work that you have to
do because it is one of life's most
rewarding experiences that you can in
those who haven't experienced it that
you could possibly imagine is having the
ability to utilize strengths to be
powerful and choosing to not and if you
aren't making that decision that just
means you're weak and that's no way to
live I'll see you next week
Betty okay that's alright I'll play okay
[Music]